i'm igor and today we're going to talk
about data reliability engineering and i
know it's right before lunch so i'm
going to try to get through this and
we'll do some q a at the end
so
why are we even here and who am i and
why does this even matter to anybody
so
i'm igor i'm the co-founder and cto at
big i we are a data observability
platform
uh
before big i i was at uber i was the
one of the first people called the data
engineer at uber uh set up a lot of the
original data warehouse stack and built
a lot of internal data tooling at uber
data reliability was a problem there
it's a problem at every company if you
work for a company you probably have
data problems and this is why big i got
started and let's talk about
specifically
what kinds of problems do we mean when
we talk about data reliability problems
well
every business has different needs for
their data it can span
everything between actual financials
billing customers making sure that your
accounts payable are getting tracked in
the uber example are drivers getting
paid we have incentive programs and if
those incentive programs
don't get computed correctly then
drivers don't get paid the right amount
so data reliability was really important
for us then as well
on top of that you might have compliance
risk
everyone here probably has got had to go
through some sort of audit whether
that's sock 2
iso 2701
whatever it is you need to make sure
that the data that you're using for all
of your business processes whether
they're revenue generating or not
is reliable and compliant
and finally and this is the most under
represented part of um data reliability
is the actual wasted time from engineers
and other employees in your company
if you've ever looked at a broken
dashboard if you've ever had an
executive that got a report and they
said
i don't know if this dashboard looks
correct i don't if something looks
suspicious about this they're going to
go message the data team the data team
now has to go back
and
run some queries figure out where it's
coming from all of this time is being
wasted the debt engineers time is being
wasted because they can't pinpoint where
something's going wrong the executive's
time is being wasted because they have
to manually now dis
check the dashboard and now they
distrust it and now every week they're
going to spend a couple of extra minutes
trying to figure out is the data still
wrong
and if you add up all of this uh wasted
effort and all of this risk
there was a report i'm pretty sure this
is gartner and i really wish i cited it
because i don't remember but every year
poor data quality cost companies on
average 20 uh 12.9 million dollars
now big is a small company this is
effectively our annuals uh close to our
annual spend not exactly but
this is a very large number for large
organizations fortune 500s this can get
into hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars especially when
you're talking about revenue uh issues
coming from data reliability
so
let's talk about how we even got here
why why is data reliability important
now why haven't we been talking about
this
a few years ago
well
data engineering and the data landscape
is evolving similarly to how software
evolved but with a bit of a delay
so if you think back to
early 2000s software was built and
deployed on bare metal racks that sat in
a closet somewhere and you had to
manually pick up a server and stick it
in the rack and if you needed more
capacity you go and you buy another
server and you stick it in the rack and
you wire it up and that's where you
deploy all of your
software
then aws came along and said well push a
button and get a new server and get your
database set up and it's all going to
work and it's all going to be well
connected and networked and you can
deploy your new application in a matter
of minutes
that was impossible and so now a bunch
of software engineers are saying great i
can build software faster so i'm going
to go build
five applications and deploy all of them
but now you have the problem of like how
do i actually automate that deployment
how do i make sure that my applications
get out so now you have all the ci cd
pipelines and you have github and you
have jenkins and i know jenkins a little
before this but
illustrative point
you use the deployment pipelines in
order to automate a lot of the processes
that didn't need automation before
and now that you've automated those
processes what's the next problem that
you encounter well
are my applications up and running
are they
serving the customer's use case are they
uh what's the latency on them what's the
qps is something falling over or not
that sort of monitoring used to be
reported by a customer someone goes out
there and says
hey i can't load your website great
someone's gonna have to go and check and
maybe restart a server or two
so you have companies like datadog new
relic app dynamics dynatrace who
built monitoring observability for the
infrastructure and application layer
so
now that we
got there with the software in the
software space let's track this again
but in the data landscape
so we start with
cloud warehouses going back to the
infrastructure talk when i uh started
working on data warehouses i used
vertica
and vertica was deployed on physical
machines in a data center you had to
install a package on all of them you
have to make sure the networking was
right
this was a complete nightmare
and
circa 2012
13 you started getting redshift you
started getting
snowflake you started bigquery
eventually it got there as well where
the infrastructure for data became easy
i when we wanted to set up our data
warehouse i went to snowflake and i
typed in my credit card number and i
clicked go and i could run a query two
minutes later
it's amazing would not be able to do
that 10 years ago so now that i have
infrastructure what's the next step
we'll get the data in the infrastructure
and so you have your five trends and
stitches and segments and all of that
and you're getting the data in and dbt
is helping you transform it and this is
all fine and dandy but now because it's
so easy to get stuff in and it's so easy
to spin up new data warehouse
infrastructure
now we have
the last problem which is reliability
how do i know that my data's there that
it's being
on time that it looks like what i expect
it to look like that it's serving the
need that i want from it
and
data reliability wasn't a problem in the
past because data could only scale as
fast as teams could scale
if i have to
in order to get a new data source write
new code
maybe even plug in a new machine to
expand my cluster because i don't have
enough space to store it takes time
there's processes we can work through
that
but now that data's scaling you need
processes to ensure data reliability at
a much
more automated and reliable way than you
did before
so
this is tip the typical pattern that a
company follows when they start setting
up their data stack so we talked about
infrastructure that's
snowflake and bigquery and all of those
and you have your compute and you have
your airflows to orchestrate your stuff
and you're getting data in and next
thing you do is you completely skip over
all the operations part of this and you
say well i want to build dashboards and
machine learning models because that's
the cool part
so then you start building dashboards
and you get tableau and you get mode and
you get looker and you just representing
these dashboards and then maybe you get
some machine learning going and you're
building or trading all these models
and then you realize that
this isn't sustainable nobody knows
where any of these dashboards are nobody
knows what they mean nobody knows
if they can use them if they can trust
them nobody knows how their changes are
affecting
anyone else in the organization
and then everyone ends up backtracking
into operations
which is discovery data catalogs
nowadays um uh address a lot of this
ownership data modeling
and obviously reliability is part of
this
addresses quality addresses lineage
where is the data coming from what is it
affecting
all of this tooling necessary to
operate your data team and your
organization at scale
is an afterthought
and that's a problem when you're scaling
much faster than your team is scaling
and we we here at big eye believe that
build the pyramid in the right order and
definitely not forget about operations
halfway through
but
let's move on this is
the the way that companies build their
data stack
so then
if this is what the stack is then what
is data reliability engineering what are
we going to talk about today
well let's go back to site reliability
engineering sres
go back to that slide where i talked
about how software
became more automated easier to deploy
easier to monitor
because there was so much software
companies now needed to have processes
and teams in place
in order to
know how to operate and work with that
software
and those teams started becoming called
site reliability engineering teams and
google
wrote a giant manifesto on how to do
site reliability engineering and in that
book they talked about the seven
principles of sre
and it all boils down to the concept of
treating
your applications
as
with the same sort of
intentionality that you would treat any
other business process
and creating scalable processes and
solutions in order to create reliable
software systems
so these are the seven risks seven
principles embrace risk
everything's gonna break just accept it
and learn how to deal with that
setting standards everything you ever
you need to set standards otherwise you
don't know what you're measuring
yourself against
what is good what is the right standard
for your data for your application
reducing toil nobody wants to push the
same script over and over again if you
get woken up at 2 am because you're
getting paged because the system is down
you don't want to think what the next
step is you want to go push a button and
have something solve that problem for
you
monitor everything there's a lot of
systems out there and we should be
monitoring everything because the
interdependencies are so complex that
nobody actually knows about them if
you're not monitoring everything then
you're probably not catching the things
that you need to be catching
using automation
this goes a little bit hand-in-hand with
reducing toil but automating as many
processes as possible
helps you
overcome the barrier of knowledge and
especially tribal knowledge within an
organization about how to fix things if
you can automate the fixing of those
things
control your releases don't make changes
without knowing what those changes are
going to do
we talked a lo i briefly mentioned
lineage i know lineage is a very popular
topic in the data space right now
part of the whole point of lineage is
understanding where are things coming
from where they where are they going to
so that when you are making changes you
are intentional about your changes and
you know what your changes are going to
affect
and finally favor simplicity
systems shouldn't be complex
using complex systems makes them less
reliable and you want
reliability by way of some by way of
simplicity because if you can understand
the system and you can understand how it
operates and what it impacts you can
then
what make it much more reliable
so this is sre
and the principles that sre introduced
so now let's talk about data reliability
engineering
so dre
how we've summarized it is treating data
quality like it's an engineering problem
rather than approaching data quality
from the perspective of well there's
going to be an analyst and the analyst
is going to look at the dashboard and
they can figure it out because they can
run the queries and they know the data
that doesn't scale that doesn't none of
these principles apply to that process
if you treat data quality like an
engineering problem then what you're
actually doing
is you're saying i will build solutions
and systems and processes around this
that are repeatable that are reliable
that i can actually
trust
my not just myself but the rest of my
team to be able to execute and ensure
the reliability of my data
so
going back to that pyramid that i showed
earlier
data operations is a really broad space
it covers a lot of territory
data operations covers everything from
as i mentioned discovery access controls
privacy security
how the data's being used the
performance of your queries optimizing
that performance there's a lot of things
in data ops
and
data reliability engineering is really
a part of it it encompa it talks about
the practices and tools that you need to
have
in order to
ensure a lot of the um reliability that
is core to the rest of the
data ops
tool tool chain so when we talk about
data reliability engineering we're
talking about practices like setting
slas for your products applications of
slas why don't your dashboards
instrumenting this having incident
management processes monitoring tracking
alerts over time tracking response rates
having run books all these processes and
tools that are necessary but this is not
the whole picture
and
we can have another talk about data ops
at some point in the future but that
would take a lot longer than 45 minutes
so
i've talked a lot about these conceptual
terms of dre and pro practices and tools
and you're like well that's great igor
but what am i actually going to do with
this how do i get started well let's
look at some examples of dre in the real
world
circuit breakers from intuit
there's a little blog post link if you
google circuit breakers you'll intuit
circuit breakers you'll find it
so
circuit breakers is a tool at intuit
that
automates the
data flow based on some quality checks
circuit breakers allows you to define
conditions under which data is not fit
for use
and it automatically stops the pipeline
and says nope this data is bad i don't
trust it if i keep the data flowing then
there's going to be consequences
downstream
what principles
is this touching well embracing risk
data is going to break
they have accepted the fact that data is
going to break so they need to do
something about it
they automate the stopping of the
process this isn't an alert that gets
sent to a data engineer who then has to
wake up at 2 am and push a button to
stop a pipeline because nobody ever
wants to do that and then you're going
to forget to turn on the pipeline again
and then the data stale and you have an
even bigger problem
so automating the
start and stop process of the pipeline
is really important in this case
especially at the scale that intuit is
operating at
and finally favoring simplicity this is
a diagram from their blog post it's two
boxes
this is about as simple of a process and
a tool as you can get data is bad stop
the flow data is good start the flow
you don't need a complex system
in order to start practicing and having
better highly higher reliable reliable
data
midas from airbnb
so
midas is a way for uh that airbnb allows
you to certify data sets as effectively
golden
part as of the certification process
includes understanding
what uh what does the data mean
does it actually
comply with the expectations of the
business for that data
and also tracking the reliability and
accuracy of over time because if it
becomes less reliable
then it shouldn't be a golden data set
so
this is actually much more interesting
because this is less automation this is
much more
policy this is a lot more about the
practices that the organization has
actually put together in order to make
sure that their data systems are
reliable
what principles are we talking about
here
setting standards
they set the standards for what does it
mean for a data set to be golden what do
what do you have to have what do you
have to ensure about your data for it to
be considered
certified by the midas touch
i'm sure there's a pun there somewhere
controlling releases
you can't just change a minus data set
because it's being tracked
you know what the expectations about it
are and if those expectations aren't met
then you can't change it
you can't also just
say yes my data set is golden and you
can trust it has to go through a process
you have to control the release of the
certification
so that you don't get
a ton of erroneous data that nobody
actually understands and nobody knows
who certified it
and finally
again favor simplicity it's a little
there's a little box on a page somewhere
that just says this is certified great
you don't have to have all these complex
integrations you don't have to push this
information out to users and a million
different uis you have a single place
you put a little gold gold stamp on it
you call it a day
i mean i am oversimplifying i am sorry
if there are any airbnb folks here i
obviously have not worked with this
directly but i am
paraphrasing
uh finally um uber data quality
everything on uber started with the u so
udq from uber
this is
probably one of the more complex systems
uh that and examples there's again all
these have blog posts you can look these
up um
after the fact
um
uber's uber system was uh more complex
because it actually integrated a lot of
the tools together in order to form this
data reliability
story
so
there's a lot here about how the compute
works how the tests are being run and
how they're stored and how they're
changed over time and where the lineage
service actually talks uh talks to the
testing service and
understands the impact of it
the reason that uber was able to do this
is because
there was a massive data team and uber
built everything in-house and so
everything in built-in house means that
you can actually build all of these
highly customized tools that interact
well together
much harder to do when you're starting
to duct tape together different vendors
and different pieces of open source
technology
but if you have a concrete problem in a
concrete domain it becomes very easy to
build these hyper-specific integrated
tools
so what principles are we talking about
here embracing risk uber had a lot of
pipelines they broke all the time
but having this this tool
um on having this tool chain that
allowed you to say we understand that
and we just want to start tracking it we
want to make sure that we can react to
it appropriately was is extremely
important for an organization that size
reducing toil
this system because it's so integrated
because it's so connected
reduced a lot of the overhead of
collecting this information yourself you
didn't have to go run queries you didn't
have to go and
figure out when was this table last
updated who's querying it what's the
upstream
the system provided you all that
information in one cohesive view
and finally use automation this is all
automated the only par interaction of
the user with this
system is through the configuration
tools you see up top the dashboarding
the the quality tool you that has the ui
and that goes through the apis and the
system just handles the rest of it
itself and just runs and works
automating this means
that i as a data user just have to
define once what do i care about and the
system can take care of itself until i
tell it otherwise
so
thanks for coming in my talk hopefully
you all learned a little bit something
about data reliability engineering and
if you have been inspired to
pursue the lofty goal of having
perfectly reliable data at your
organization come to my office hours i'd
be happy to talk about how to make that
a reality